welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and you're locked
into the channel where we explain all
the latest movies TV shows games and
more we've been over DC's latest film
Joker with a fine-tooth comb and in the
background of scenes we've noticed a lot
of numbers that seem to have a hidden
meaning to them this episode were going
to be going over the numbers themselves
and discussing what they could mean and
why they're so important there's gonna
be heavy heavy spoilers here so if you
haven't seen Joker yet and don't want
anything about the movie ruined then I
highly recommend that you turn off now
without the way I just want to give a
huge thank you for clicking this video
now let's go over the hidden numbers in
Joker
okay so Joker is a film that throughout
feels like it's building towards
something special in the end this turns
out to be the reveal of comic books
biggest baddie and the introduction of
the titular character throughout the
film there's a clear indication that
there's a countdown in place and during
several of the movies major moments that
appears a number in the background of
scenes that signifies that the film is
ramping up the first instance of the
numbers comes when Joker is sitting with
his psychiatrist during the scene we can
see a clock behind Arthur which clearly
states 11 minutes past 11:00 this seems
rather innocuous however when the
psychiatrist mentions the time that
Joker spent at Arkham we get a quick cut
of him in a Cell smashing his head
against the wall in the top right of the
screen we can clearly see another clock
which also says 11 minutes past 11:00
it's unlikely that this wasn't purposely
put there even though director Todd
Phillips has stated that it's a
coincidence and we do see numbers appear
later in the movie now I haven't been
able to catch a number 10 in the film
but I'll give my theory on where it
could be later as we get further down
the list let me know in the comments if
you spotted it but I do have an idea
where it could be which I'll discuss
with 0.8 anyway right after Joker kills
her three businessmen on Gotham subway
we can clearly see a large nine on a
post indicating the number of the
platform Joker also fires nine bullets
into the attackers and to me at least
this has been put in place for a reason
especially as revolvers tend to carry a
lot less ammo and we never see
him reload this is a massive moment for
Arthur and sort of begins as birth as
the character from here Arthur runs home
stops in the bathroom to do some
ballroom dancing and then goes to his
neighbor's apartment which just so
happens to be 8 B now this is where I
think 10 comes into play as Arthur lives
down the hall so potentially he could
live in apartment 10 but like I said let
me know if I'm wrong and who knows I
might update this video later down the
line from here we jump forward quite a
bit in the film - when Joker learns
about his mother's time at arkham asylum
after stealing a psych file from a clerk
played by Brian Tyree Henry Joker runs
away - reader on stairwell 7 this is
another huge moment for the character
and cements that everything he had
believed in his life up until this point
was a lie and then it was all his
mother's fault
later in the film after Joker has just
killed his coworker and gets chased by
policemen on his way to the Murray
Franklin show he boards the train on
platform 6 now similar to 10 have been
unable to fully confirm 5 however after
doing some research Reddit user f your
couch said that the Joker himself may be
the one displaying this number when
Joker exits the train he holds up all
fingers and thumbs on his hands and
gleefully dances down the platform this
could be him displaying the number 5 and
know this may be a reach it's also the
only time I can see the number appear in
between 6 & 4 which is the next entry
this comes when Joker is backstage and
Murray and his producer into the room
whilst Joker is talking to the character
we can clearly see a giant number 4 in
the background and the number of Joker's
dressing-room is 4 0 4 from here Joker
goes onto the Mary Franklin show where
there are three guests and the character
admits that he killed three people on
the subway Joker is also filmed by
camera three in the conversation Murray
mentions that two federal agents are in
critical condition which is referring to
the policeman that chase Joker earlier
on the train and when killing the
character Joker shoots Murray a total of
two times the final one which pretty
much comes at the birth of Joker can be
seen when Arthur is being taken away in
the back of a police car after he's
rescued by an ambulance there crashes
into the side of the car we can see in
the background that the movie theater at
the location is named
ace in the hole aces of course usually
associated with the number one in card
games and another thing that comes with
every pack of cards is a joker I believe
that this is the final occurrence of the
pattern from here Joker then stands on
top of the police car as a symbol of
Gotham's destruction as well as the
chaos that he is unleashed on the city
we see the Wayne's murdered and the
birth of Batman Begins roughly at the
same time that Joker is created though
Arthur is arrested and locked up in
Arkham Asylum it's clear to me at least
that this countdown in the background of
scenes was slowly ticking away until the
destruction of Gotham and its biggest
Saviour and worst enemy were created
this ace in the hole could either
symbolise the end of the countdown or it
could also showcase that Gotham's ace in
the hole to stop all this is Batman the
sign appears above the theater which is
of course what we see the Wayne's
exiting before they're killed right in
front of Bruce I guess it works either
way and you can really interpret this as
Joker being the ace in the hole that
saves the citizens have got them from
their rich rulers or the birth of Batman
it's awesome to me that this was seated
away in the film and though Todd
Phillips is strongly denied putting any
Easter eggs or secret messages in the
movie I think this is far more than a
coincidence and is purposely put there
to countdown to the massive moment we
saw a similar aesthetic in How I Met
Your Mother in which numbers counting
down from 50 were placed in two scenes
and I think that this was also put in
place for a similar reason Joker is a
massively complex movie with multiple
layers and a definitely thing that this
adds a lot to it and makes the film
worth going back to
now obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on these numbers and if you
know is tenant buyer any point in the
film make sure you leave it in the
comment section below also just want to
give a huge shout outs to youtuber wars
to you who have been going back and
forth with over this theory for the last
couple of days I've linked his channel
in the description below so make sure
you head over there after this and also
shout outs reddit users send your Bolin
who found a lot of these and was a huge
help when putting the video together if
you enjoyed this video then please like
it because a lot of work went into it
and make sure you check out my breakdown
of who I think the joke is real father
in the movie is we did the digital DNA
test so if you still have questions
about whether either Wayne or not and
make sure you click that at the end
you want to come chat to me after the
video then follow me on twitter at
definition YT or head over to my discord
server which would be linked in the
description below those are the best
ways to keep up to date with all the
latest videos so hopefully see you over
there after this this is a channel for
people who are super into superheroes so
if that's the kind of thing you like hit
subscribe thanks again for taking the
time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]